michel pronovost apprécié la quiétude de
son chalet imminent supprimés il peut
profiter de la nature loin des foules et
de l'aco vide si j'attrape là que
viennent avec mon système immunitaire
déficient
qu'est-ce que d'en mourir en fait moi
parce que même vacciné bon nombre de
personnes immunosupprimées demeure moins
bien ou pas du tout protéger contre le
virus aux neuf
l'abolition du port du masque dans les
lieux publics au québec génèrent donc le
stress de plus pour des personnes comme
michel des gens y pensent que la
pandémie fini mais n'en avaient pas fini
je me sentis moins protégés qu'avant que
lorsque le masque était obligatoire
l'association des patients
immunodéficients du québec espère que la
population sera bienveillante envers
ceux qui n'ont pas le choix de le porter
on veut surtout pas que ces personnes-là
se fasse jugé se fasse ostracisé se
fasse m de couple et on souhaite aussi
que les personnes qui auront des
symptômes de la coved le porte au milieu
de son puits qui dit soins dits des gens
courageux l'ordre des pharmaciens et
encourage d'ailleurs les clients elle
portait en succursale puisqu'on y
retrouve des personnes vulnérables dans
s'est tous mis ensemble du comment on
peut protéger le mieux la population nos
patients qui viennent chez nous d'abord
et nous équipe enfin monsieur aussi
parce qu'une contamination dans le
laboratoire de l'employée salwa des
effets catastrophiques
cet infectiologue microbiologiste
médical crois que la santé des personnes
à risque devraient primer le port de
masque peut être un inconvénient c'est
sûr
mais quand on rentre dans un endroit
charmant l'inconvénient est temporaire
mais dans le processus on peut sauver la
vie de quelqu'un dont le docteur
viennent souligner que le masque demeure
un outil important pour protéger toutes
les personnes vulnérables comme celles
atteintes d'insuffisance cardiaque ou
rénale les femmes enceintes et pas
seulement les immuno supprimés ici
valérie michaela ben haddou canada
montréal